[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
my name is Uta and I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about Teen Mental Health
in high school teen mental health in
high school is a pressing concern that
requires a comprehensive examination of
the various factors contributing to
mental health issues as well as a
discussion of strategies to promote a
mental well-being in
adolescence adolescent is a crucial
developmental stage marked by physical
emotional and social changes and the
experiences during this time can
significantly impact an individual's
mental health here we will delve into
the factors influencing teen mental
health issues and explore strategies to
F to foster a positive mental
environment for high school
students factors contributing to teen
mental health issues
use academic pressure high school can be
academically demanding with rigorous
coursework exams and the pressure to
excel this pressure can lead to stress
anxiety and
depression peer pressure adolesents
often face peer pressure to conform to
social norms which can lead to feelings
of inadequacy low self-esteem and mental
health
issues bullying bullying whether
physical or cyber bullying can have
several psychological effects on teens
leading to depression anxiety and a
sense of
isolation family issues family problems
such as divorce conflict or parental
substance abuse can impact a teenagers
mental
health adolesents who feel isolated or
lack of strong support network may
experience feelings of loneliness
depression and
anxiety experimentation with drugs and
alcohol is common among high school
students and can lead to addiction and
mental health
issues the pressure to conform to
unrealistic beauty standards can lead to
body image issues and eating disorders
in
teens ways to promote mental well-being
education and
awareness schools should provide mental
health education and awareness programs
to help students understand their
emotions and recognize signs of mental
distress schools should offer concealing
Services where students can talk to
train Prof professionals about their
concerns schools should promote a
balanced approach to academics
emphasizing learning over grades
encourage teachers to be flexible and
supportive Implement anti-bullying
programs and a zero tolerance policy to
create safe and supportive School
environment encourage the formation of
support groups where students can
discuss their problems and share
experiences encourage parents to be
actively involved in their child's life
fostering open communication and
support promote physical activity and a
balanced diet and adequate sleep as
these are essential for overall
well-being teach stress management
techniques such as mindfulness and
relaxation
exercises to help students goope with
academic and social
pressure help students develop critical
thinking skills to
evaluate media messages about beauty
embody image
realistically identify warning signs of
mental health issues early and provide
appropriate intervention and treatment
involve the local community and mental
health organizations to provide
additional resources and support for
struggling teams create an inclusive and
accepting School environment that
respect diversity and
individually teachers play a crucial
role in supporting teens mental health
in a school set
here are some key ways in which teachers
should be around teens's mental
health teachers should educate
themselves about common teen mental
health issues such as anxiety depression
and
stress understanding the signs and
symptoms of these conditions is
essential for early identification and
support actively listen to your students
pay attention to their emotional
well-being and be approachable when they
need to talk sometimes students just
need someone to listen without
judgment familiarize yourself with the
school's concealing services and
resources be ready to refer students to
mental health professionals when
necessary discussing mental health
openly in the classroom can help share
stories and resources related to mental
health to lets you don't know it's okay
to talk about it keep keep an eye out of
the changes in Behavior mood or academic
performance these changes can be
indicators of mental health concerns if
you notice something unusual reach out
to the students
privately teach students about the
importance of self-care encourage them
to manage stress through healthy habits
such as exercise sleep and relaxation
techniques recognize that students have
different learning styles and needs be
flexible in your teaching methods and
assessments work closely with school
concealers and other support staff to
ensure a holistic approach to students
mental health share concern and
collaborate on strategies to help
students show empathy and compassion
when students are struggling let them
know that you care about their
well-being and that they are not alone
in their
struggle be mindful of the workload you
assign overloading students with
assignments and assessments can
contribute to Stress and
Anxiety ensure that he workload is
resonable and
manageable teachers can serve as role
models for resilience and coping
strategies share your own experiences of
facing challenges and overcoming them
promote support networks and group
activities that encourage positive
interaction among students this can help
combat feelings of isolation and promote
a sense of
belonging maintain open lines of
communication with parents or Guardians
share concerns about the students mental
health with their caregivers and
collaborate on strategies for the
support participate in training and
professional development related to Teen
Mental Health this can enhance your
ability to support students
effectively so in conclusion addressing
Teen Mental Health in high school is a
complex and multifaced challenge by
recognizing the factors that contribute
to mental health issues and implementing
a range of strategies to promote a
mental well-being high schools can
provide
adolescence with the support and tools
they need to navigate their critical
stage of their life
successfully it is a collective
responsibility of schools families and
communities to create a nurturing and
supportive environment for high school
students ensuring their emotional and
psychologic
well-being thank you so much for joining
us on this episode it's been an
incredible journey and we're so glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take care
[Music]